Jordan Peterson came to Senate lunch
about a half a year ago and then the
point he made he said Neil's
conservatives were just terrible
at defending conservative values then he
grant us immediate absolution
so because we never thought we'd have to
whoever thought we'd have to defend the
benefit of having a mom and a dad okay
listen there are other ways okay but can
we at least acknowledge it's really nice
for children to have you know a father
who provides discipline and you know the
mother the you know again that's that's
a good arrangement it stood the test of
time we never thought we'd have to
defend that we never thought our
daughters would have to compete against
biological males
then be expected to take a shower in the
same locker room and then have a judge
order
the biological male take showers in the
girls locker room
never thought we'd be pushing back on
school administrators that want to
administer gender blocking drugs to our
children and not tell the parents
I'm Dave Rubin and we are once again in
DC and joining me today is the
Republican senator representing the
great state of Wisconsin Senator Ron
Johnson finally welcome to the Reuben
report well appreciate you having me on
I think I've had basically everybody
here this you're a rookie on the Reuben
report didn't realize that story elusive
well I told you right before we started
you have nothing to fear because I am
unvaxed and uh this has become one of
your your hardcore things what has
happened with these vaccines well it's
tragic what's happened and you know the
pandemic has exposed so many problems in
this country
um the the capture by
big farm of our federal health agencies
but also of the media and the big Tech
social media Giants as well
and the American public has not been
given the truth uh the agency has not
been transparent so the big Pharma
companies haven't been transparent uh
and you know I'm certainly not an
anti-vaxxer but based on what's happened
here I've certainly started asking a
whole lot more questions so when you ask
those questions specifically in the in
the hearings here at the Capitol and you
know the congressmen and senators get
out there it seems like we catch people
in lies and Fouch you'll be caught
saying we didn't do gain a function we
did I didn't say masks I did Etc et
cetera I think one thing that people are
getting very frustrated with now is that
it doesn't seem like anyone pays a price
at the end nobody gets fired nobody gets
removed for their job you know it's like
we live in this time of cancel culture
we'll cancel a comedian for a joke and
yet the people that are really doing
some nefarious stuff it's almost
irrelevant well as it relates to the
pandemic and the coronavirus you know
you've got the covert cartel and that is
the by the administration The Better
Health agencies big Pharma then the
Legacy median the big Tech social media
Giants there you go there's there's the
cover cartel they're the ones
collectively that sabotage really
treatment
I can't tell you the exact moment the
decision was made that the only solution
to the pandemic was going to be vaccines
vaccines vaccines and as a result we
better not have any therapies because it
might be difficult to get an emergency
use authorization if there is those
types of therapies because you actually
can't right technically you can't get
the emergency wow yeah again you know in
Washington you see their rules until
people don't want to follow the rules
right but the fact the matter is I
totally believe the doctors who say that
hundreds of thousands of people lost
their lives they didn't have to because
they weren't being treated early and it
is bizarre I'm almost 68 years old as
long as I've been alive the medical
advices I've been early detection allows
for early treatment produces better
results right
do that with everything that's why we
try and get going there detect cancers
early so we can treat them
um but now with coven we were happy to
spend tens of billions of dollars on
tests and we did spend tens of billions
of dollars in tests and you can argue
about the PCR test okay
and then so what good did that do I mean
once the horse is out of the barn the
cat was out of the bag we weren't
stopping the spread so the testing
didn't stop the spread and then we told
people well don't do anything go home be
afraid isolate yourself hope you don't
get so sick they have to check yourself
in the hospital where they'll inject
about 3 000 bucks worth of Remedy sphere
in your arm that might take out your
kidneys put you on a vent 89 of the
people that put on uh ventilator never
came off it not alive this was insane
what we did and yeah I'm thoroughly
convinced that this I always call it a
cornucopia full of
widely available
proven safe generic drugs
use both on label and off-label they
worked I had enough people come to me I
could refer them to doctors I followed
up on the case I mean some remark remark
remarkable results but it's all being
denied now they're they're you know
doctoring at different uh studies uh
underpowering for example use of
ivermectin to give it for three days on
an empty stomach well into the course of
of your disease I mean it's just it's
it's sick when you're aware of what's
Happening Here and how the cover cartel
continues to cover up for its uh
miserably failed response to coven but
again
the body count is way too high they
can't admit they are wrong
and I just described using the cover
cartel they have the power
to make it almost impossible to prove
them wrong so that's why they're out uh
taking away people's you know doctor's
certification that had the courage and
compassion to treat covid they're
destroying these people they're
vilifying them
um
it's it's it's it's sick so is there
anything we can do about it I mentioned
here right before we started I saw you a
few weeks ago at Governor DeSantis he's
doing these blueprint events I think the
one that we were at was an education one
but you know he's done one on covet he's
got this panel that it seems to me some
states might start doing some things but
maybe at the federal level
you know you know what a lonely voice I
am here in Washington DC now most of my
colleagues pushed the vaccine on their
constituents they don't want to admit
they're wrong uh doctors don't want to
admit they're wrong again the cover
cartel will never admit they're wrong so
the only the only solution I have here
is uh uncovering and exposing the truth
and that's what I'm dedicated to doing
you know
I held can't call them hearings or
events you know I did that uh you know
after I lost my chairmanship now as a
chairman I mean this is odd too nobody
else is holding hearings on early
treatment
I'm the guy that holds a hearing first
of all in February Roundtable with Scott
golly found out we don't make drugs here
we spent trillions of dollars we didn't
solve that problem we wouldn't spend a
dime on onshoring drug manufacturing
okay uh May of 2020 I held a hearing
with Johnny and Edis trying to put
things in perspective you know he did
the analysis of the princess Cruz which
pretty well stood the test of time now
right the infection mortality rate of
covet across the uh for anybody under 70
is actually less than a bad flu season
okay this was not a disease that we
should have been freaking out about yeah
serious if you're elderly if you had
certain comorbidities but we never
should have shut the economy down so I
held that hearing in May of 2020 I also
had Pierre Corey they're talking about
corticosteroids he was Savaged on that
until all of a sudden the UK studied
with dexamethasone which is a cortical
steroid proved those were effective I
had the hearing with Peter McCulloch and
George Farid and Harvey rich on early
treatment in November uh
we were labeled the snake oil sales from
the Senate by Dr Zha who never treated a
covert patient filed that up with the
hearing Pierre Courier and Ivermectin uh
then I got to connect with the vaccine
injured Community held events okay now I
don't have the power but anyway those
early hearings
those weren't conducted by the help
committees
or I was doing that as chairman of
Homeland Security government Affairs
right again I thought this was insane
they were shutting down our economy but
everybody seemed to be on board with
that do you feel that really from day
one because I always say to people and
and as I mentioned I'm unvaxed I've
become sort of I'm not an unvaxxer in
the in as you said in that traditional
sense of the phrase but once they
started with mandates and after two
weeks to me that was it once they once
the two weeks became 15 days I was like
uh-uh something else is going on here
were you feeling that really from day
one well as soon as I heard about it
because I grant everybody a certain
leash so if you you don't expect you
follow my Clips but uh I'm the guy who
said probably in March of 2020 it wasn't
March that listen we tragically lose
thirty six thousand people a year in the
highway but we don't shut our highways
down we need a transportation system we
can't shut the economy down yeah we
can't shut it down fauci heard that
comment so it was I was way out there
you know no it was actually a pretty
good analogy we never should have
already kind of et cetera shutter
economy down not even for a couple days
a couple weeks again I I understand the
fear back then and maybe that's what
separated me from others well that's why
I'm asking I wasn't freaked out about
this yeah I was concerned I mean you see
you know the folks in Moon suits you
know doctors treat Cove patients they're
they're dropping like flies yeah it was
something to be concerned about but you
know once Johnny Unitas did that
analysis on the Princess Cruise and that
certainly calmed me down
um but I also I was I understood the
reality situation you can't shut the
economy down and look at how we shut it
down
let liquor stores open shut down
churches shut down all the mom and pop
Main Street businesses let the big box
stores open I mean this was this was
sick yeah Bobby Kennedy writes in his
letter to Liberal quotes a study
conducted in 2021 so there's about a
four trillion dollar transfer of wealth
from the middle class to the big Tech
social media Giants yeah gee why were
they censoring information yeah well why
were they pushing the shutdowns and be
so supportive of again what I always
call our miserable are miserably failed
response to Kobe right and basically
we're all sitting at home ordering
everything on Amazon instead of going to
those the few mom and pop stores that
might have spotted her so by shutting
down our economy by
you know printing trillions of dollars I
mean the economic Devastation of the
pandemic and how we mishandled it I mean
I don't know if they're ever really
fully dig ourselves out of it and then
the human toll too I mean people died
that didn't have to die
you mentioned following some of your
Clips you had a clip uh about two months
ago now on Meet the Press with Chuck
Todd where he was going after you and
you really threw it back to him so I'm
going to throw to the clip you have a
crime that you think Hunter Biden
committed because I've yet to see
anybody explain it is not a crime to
make money off your last name
so Chuck you ought to read the Marco
Polo report where they detail all kinds
of potential crimes you know Senator
grass
potential
about about potentials about thirty
thousand about thirty thousand dollars
chuck chuck is it a crime to be
soliciting and purchasing uh
prostitution in potentially European sex
trafficking operations is that a crime
because Chuck grass and I laid out about
thirty thousand dollars uh paid by
Hunter Biden to those types of of
individuals over uh December 2018 2019
about thirty thousand dollars this is
about the same time that President Biden
offered to pay about a hundred thousand
dollars of Hunter Biden's bills I mean
again that's that's just some
information I don't know exactly but I
don't care all right it doesn't it
doesn't really look on the it sounds
sleazy as you know I'll take care I'll
take care of your word that you're
ethically bothered by Hunter Biden I'm
curious though you seem to have you not
uh Chuck you know part of the problem
and this is pretty obvious to anybody
watching this is you don't invite me on
to interview me you invite me on to
argue with me you know I'm just trying
to lay out the facts that certainly
Senator grass and I uncovered they were
suppressed they were censored they
interfered in the 2020 election
conservatives understand that
unfortunately liberals in the media
don't and that's part of the things that
part of the reasons our politics are
inflamed is we do not have an unbiased
uh media we don't it's unfortunate I'm
all for a free press more unbiased seems
like you like fighting people on
television I kind of like you were ready
I kind of like to argue yeah yeah it was
you know
unfortunately in America today we don't
have an unbiased media yeah we don't
have journalists anymore
we have advocates for the left that you
know Chuck Todd doesn't uh invite me on
to interview me he invites me on to you
know argue with me or set me up yeah you
know use me as a foil to make his uh his
leftist point uh you know that was two
years since I had a similar situation
with him after January 6. where he said
you know I think he accused me you know
Senator your your sightings lighting the
fuse you're starting the fire so no no
Chuck you are good yeah you are okay uh
and it's true I mean for four years
conservatives have to watch the Russian
hoax the growth where where let's face
it the media set aside any pretense of
being unbiased and they said no we we
can't be we can't be unbiased because we
gotta take down Trump we notice that as
conservatives and you know so you go all
the way through them then all of a
sudden there are all kinds of
irregulators in the election there just
were that's indisputable but you
couldn't talk about them
if you did now now you're one of the
insurrectionists which by the way there
weren't thousands of armed
insurrectionists and the guy that asked
the FBI witness that that joint
committee senate committee okay if there
were if this is an armed Insurrection
how many guns you confiscate I I had no
idea she might have told me a thousand
you know zero is what she told me you
know
um they also didn't have plans that's
what I kept saying was there anyone with
the piece of paper that had a plan yeah
also we saw the video that day of people
walking between the Rope lines and the
cap that's not what an armed
Insurrection would look like yeah plus
you know we were back in business within
a few hours you know I didn't see any
fires being started
um so again Matt listen we all condemn
the violence you know it's it's a TR
it's tragic that that happened okay but
the vast majority of people came here on
January 6 were here to protest
peacefully exercise their first
amendment rights to petition their
government
um they are not domestic terrorists and
yet they're being treated as such and
now we're seeing this multiple tier
system of justice we have where the
justice department the FBI are putting
record number resources to persecute and
prosecute individuals that weren't
engaged in violence but just to make an
example of them well at the same time
they're completely ignoring
by and large the 570 riots that occurred
during the summer of 2020 2000 law
enforcement officials injured a couple
billion dollars with property damage a
couple dozen people killed during those
a couple people killed in Kenosha we're
supposed to ignore that and focus all on
one day of riding which we all condemned
you could also go out without a match
what what members of the left are
condemning all the riots
in the summer 2020 no they were
condoning well they were you know
encouraging their followers to to bail
out the rioters yeah again is the double
standard drives us nuts that's what I
was pointing out to Chuck Todd it's you
know you are so blatantly unfair so
blatantly biased that inflames the
situation you're the one laying the fuse
here if if the Press were fair and
unbiased I think our politics would be a
lot calmer and a lot less divided do you
think anything's shifting there so for
example you go on you you fight him back
rather effectively that clip goes viral
and then I think a certain amount of
people do wake up a little bit and they
go wait a minute wait a minute Chuck
Todd was acting like a Democrat lawyer
here not not an honest uh interviewer so
is that does that show you that
something's shifting at all or is that a
little pollyanish well again I think
truth has its own power uh the problem
is the truth is being suppressed and
censored and you know what I've been
telling audiences recently is I don't
think the conservative movement has
really grabbed grasped the how
pervasively and effectively
the radical left has infiltrated every
institution not not only of America but
but globally it's not a fair fight it's
not a Level Playing Field I mean the
massive stroke in the U.S to the left
was they took control of the University
system during the Vietnam war protests
in the 60s so now they control colleges
of Journalism
so they're cranking out a bunch you know
radical leftists you know Advocates and
education and that is that is where they
really are are exercising their power so
now we're what we are pushing K-12
is
it's obscene in some cases okay we're
trying to tell little boys maybe a
little girl or vice versa I mean you
don't do that to Children listen we have
compassion I understand there are people
that are are conflicted and we have all
kinds of compassion we want help folks
like that but at this point in time all
of a sudden transgenderism just
exploding in our society I don't think
it is I think it's being pushed on our
society and and again I don't think I've
said this on camera before
but the fact that we have doctors and
nurses that are mutilating children
I mean that's I mean that's a serious
operation as an adult to be to be that I
guess tormented that you actually
undergo a sex change operation
I don't see how any adult
can approve of that
you know for a child
I'm gonna see how you can do that did
you see the clip I think it was about a
week ago where uh somebody Unearthed the
clip of Rachel Levine you know the
deputy Health secretary whatever where
where he she whatever says that I I hate
this pronoun I think it's so annoying
but he basically says that he's glad
that he didn't have a sex change until
after he had kids because his kids are
the love of his life and at the same
time now he's saying kids should undergo
these surgeries he's pushing that to
forget for minors
again can a minor get a tattoo
minor can't drink
and there's all again and there's a
reason that we protect minors that way
okay again Council people all kinds of
but don't push it on them and don't
mutilate them it's irreversible now now
of course there are some celebrated
cases of people you know transgender
individuals who had the sex change and
they kind of like to get their their old
gender back yeah oh it's a huge thing
it's it's it's it's just it's so hard to
watch I mean my wife she's always
looking at these things and she wants
from showing to me and I you know Jane I
please don't it's it's it's too awful to
look at it's just too tortuous so when
you talk to or if you talk to your
colleagues on the other side about this
stuff and this is what I ask literally
every Republican
to the Democrats pushing it believe it
did they first of all I don't talk to
you about this well no I mean yeah again
I think this first time I've ever you
know been recorded talking about you
know this is mutilation of children
um I talk about it uh and we're just
doing a bunch of events this weekend I'm
talking about uh
Jordan Peterson came to Senate lunch
about a half a year ago and then the
point he made he said you know his
conservatives were just terrible
at defending conservative values then he
grant us immediate absolution
so because we never thought we'd have to
whoever thought we'd have to defend the
benefit of having a mom and a dad okay
listen there are other ways okay but can
we at least acknowledge it's really nice
for children to have you know a father
who provides discipline and you know the
mother the you know again that's that's
a good arrangement it stood the test of
time we never thought we'd have to
defend that we never thought our
daughters would have to compete against
biological males
then be expected to take a shower in the
same locker room and then have a judge
order
the biological male take showers in the
girls locker room
never thought we'd be pushing back on
school administrators that want to
administer gender blocking drugs to our
children and not tell the parents
and then I guess then I literally go on
to say and this is very uncomfortable to
talk about
but I never I never thought I mean I
Revere Duchess nurses they saved my
daughter with a serious heart defect you
know open heart surgery the age eight
months I never thought I'd hear doctors
and nurses
would actually mutilate children
because that's what's that that's what's
happening I mean how else can you what
else can you call it I mean you take
away your god-given body parts
again as an adult I guess that's your
right nobody should have the right to
approve that for a child you know it's
interesting I don't know if you know but
I toured with Jordan Peterson for a year
and a half we did about 120 shows 20
something countries so I do know who he
is so the reference didn't go over my
head but one of the other things he says
about about the transgender issue is
that he says even for the people that
clinically have gender dysphoria that
truly at the end believe they are in the
wrong body just switching the body parts
doesn't mean you're going to be happier
or more fulfilled on the other side
because you often end up with a series
of other health problems and
psychological problems sometimes we've
shown that that doesn't help again and
that's unfortunate listen you know we
all have compassion we do yeah we have
compassion people like that but but
let's not let's not force that on to
chill I mean kids are kids you know you
can throw all kinds of weird ideas in
their head you can destroy children if
you're not educating them properly and I
would say that's pushing transgender and
transgenderism on children is not
educating kids properly so let me let's
just go deep into a couple things
because I can censor not hold him back
here and you normally don't so I'm not
surprised so you know I got like I could
pull a Chuck Tada I I got reelected I
did not want to it's obvious I did not
want to run again yeah I'm so sick of
the dysfunction of this place
the primary reason I ran again was
because nobody else was advocating for
the vaccine injured I could not turn my
back on them okay but having won the
six-year term what I've dedicated myself
and I tell crowds is you know I am
dedicated to tenaciously pursuing
uncovering and exposing the truth
pick your error what what what is the
truth so let's do it so so this
Administration to me seems either the
most generous version of it would be
that they are sort of willfully ignorant
of economics and reality when it comes
to science gender covered vaccines
whatever or they're actually malicious
I'm veering towards the malicious at
this point that they cannot be that
inept do you think that that's a fair
uh is that is that is that a fair
premise so I was able to spend some time
with David Horowitz one time I went
outside okay and so I know what his
answer would be so I'm talking to him
and goes so you know David you were a
communist your parents are kindness yes
he saw the light when his communist
buddies murdered somebody that's why
yeah
um I said so
what is it with these folks you know
what are they thinking I mean they see
where socialism communism has been tried
in the past
is failed miserably didn't work
economically it resulted in
totalitarianism tens of millions people
murdered I mean what don't they get he
said no they're utopians
they just think if you give them the
power
they're smarter and better Angels than
the stalins or the
castros or the Chavez's let's just give
them all the power so I mean I I guess
I'll take another word that you know
these they're do-gooders I think they're
utopians they think they're just so much
smarter and of course obviously by
extension we're stupid and we can't be
expected to live our own lives I mean we
will destroy the planet and you know so
they're going to be the better angels
that are going to tell us exactly how we
need to deliver lives you know how many
times we you know what kind of cars we
ought to drive you know never mind the
fact that we don't have the rare earth
minerals to produce the batteries or the
generating power to you know it's all in
it's insane I mean what what policy of
the left works
I don't know I I can't think of one I
mean their economics don't work I mean a
dolly held the start of the by
Administration is worth 87 cents today
that's that's a pretty rapid decline in
the value of the dollar you held in your
savings account in a little over two
years but what I thought it was the
inflation reduction act doesn't that
mean it reduces so now I mean brilliant
so now you had Goldman Sachs do a study
yeah published in the Wall Street
Journal or they wrote a column on this
saying that the 300 billion dollars of
tax credits for the green energy
boondoggles it's really going to cost
about 1.2 trillion and of course Janet
yells for a finance committee a couple
weeks ago and I asked I laid out listen
you know these bank failures obviously
are caused by the inflation caused the
FED to increase interest rates would
devalue the bonds put them into
bankruptcy okay let's talk about
inflation from my standpoint the three
primary causes massive deaths of
spending that's the biggest one of
course your warring fossil fuel doesn't
help driving up cost of energy and then
of course the slightest locations from
these idiotic shutdowns right she came
back so I don't think deficit spending
is a major cause of inflation
but when she says that
do you want to say here well do you
understand basic like econ 101 I mean
like well unfortunately you only have
five minutes yeah which is a real
problem with hearings okay you can't get
into a back and forth dialogue you got
five minutes you got to figure out which
is one of the reasons I like my events
yeah you know like on covid-19 a second
opinion I mean I'm there I can answer
many questions for as long as I want to
and you actually have a good dialogue
you can make sure it's a good dialogue
but no I I was pretty well shocked by
that
um
again you know I don't think the public
understands basic economics but it's
it's kind of frightening when the
treasury secretary that doesn't really
or won't acknowledge the harm that all
this massive deaths is spending has
caused you know again now we're
concerned about the money supply that
was the that was the problem the Great
Depression is foolishly they allowed the
mice Supply to decline to be reduced
which probably took a really bad
recession turned into a you know how
many year depression so we need to
understand these things but we need to
be honest and transparent about them so
what would you have done if you were in
charge of the fed and they tell you okay
silicon bank has gone down Silicon
Valley Bank has gone down and this could
trigger now you know 20 other Banks to
go down and then that triggers the big
one well first of all what do you do I
wasn't voting for all the steps of
spending so I don't think we'd have the
inflation we had but you know in that
particular circumstance let's go back
2008-2009 what I would have done there
is I would have said we're going to
suspend this Mark to Market rule because
it's destroying these banks for no
reason the the mortgage-backed
Securities weren't worth zero you know I
know the market froze so nobody could
sell them so in effect short term they
were zero but by the way I asked one of
the Federal Reserve presidents recently
I'm not going to name I said did we ever
determine what you know what percent of
value those mortgage-backed Securities
had and I don't think anybody's going to
study in that but it's probably about 90
right but we forced Banks to Mark all
those assets down to zero put them into
bankruptcy well the same thing kind of
happened here uh held the maturity those
bonds will be worth you know full value
but they were you know because of the
duration risk they had to write those
things down what I would have done is I
would have come into the fed and I would
have opened up a lending authority to
the depositors where you could okay
we're not going to
have your deposits held up in a
bankruptcy you you can borrow against
that up to a certain percent pick your
number 80 90 percent basically so they
could stay in business so they can stay
in business but you know if they were so
stupid
and negligent not to have sweep accounts
I mean people realize okay my deposit
only insured up 250 000 bucks you know
when I had my manufacturing account you
know we also had a comp sitting balance
so I was taking probably risk above that
but beyond that compensating balance for
the things we you know it would sweep
into overnight CDs or you know whatever
so you you helped so
so there is a way to mature do this
there's a way of doing that and people
weren't willing to do it so for their
negligence for their stupidity they
should take a haircut as well I mean
obviously the shareholders are wiped out
yeah that's capitalism
if you don't have a consequence for
stupid and risky Behavior well you're
just going to get stupider and more
risky Behavior so the way the way the
FED has done this and by the way do you
think they would have bailed out
depositors if if those depositors were
oh I don't know uh
oil drillers right of course refineries
uh you know it's probably or you know
gun manufacturers so let me know these
are all the little woke businesses in
Silicon Valley uh they were doing
everything you know Green energy you
know these businesses have probably
never made money you know the the right
we're probably going through for cash
sooner they than they needed to yeah so
again all the way around the way the FED
has handled this has been has mismanaged
and what it'll probably do is it'll
probably hasten the next banking crisis
and make it worse so that's a good job
is that sort of what the FED wants do
you think again going to sort of the
maliciousness versus incompetence thing
that to me it seems like the FED always
wants to get bigger the machine just
wants to get bigger right so okay the
more big things that we have that are
too big to fail we'll just keep making
them bigger and then there'll be One
bank and it'll be in this town I mean
there are people yeah there are people
saying this is the just the the game
plan the strategy to move toward a
central bank digital currency
which would give me cause for concern
um you know I mean it's long long past
to argue whether or not we should have a
Federal Reserve or not I think that's
been been decided they're not going to
go away right right but you're far
better off with decentralized power
you're far better off with a lot of
smaller Banks now you need some you do
need some big Banks you know do the big
International transactions and do things
that it'd be big businesses too some you
know some things only big businesses can
do okay but what I've seen in for
example my Plastics manufacturing plant
uh when I started that business in late
70s early 80s we probably had a couple
couple hundred potential customers my
guess is that's shrunken down to about
12 major ones because everything's
Consolidated and all these little you
know individual manufacturing you know
Plastics manufacturers therm reformers
and stuff and you know great little
businesses for little towns and stuff
they get gobbled up and you know that
manufacturing goes from theirs into a
much larger plant that's not good you
know it's small businesses that are that
are the engines of innovationary in our
economy and provide the kind of
competition you really need in a
competitive system so I don't like to
see all this consolidation I think
that's something that the federal
government does have role to play in
terms of antitrust I think we need to re
rethink and rework the antitrust laws
it's all around you know benefit
consumer and that makes sense but you
know how do you handle these big Tech
social media Giants where it's all free
so it's almost impossible to prove
consumer harm but then you can improve
societal harm sure when you start seeing
the cooperation with government
officials to censor information I mean
something something has to be done about
that but again Democrats won't help us
legislatively on that because it
you know plays their advantage is that
the weird thing that we find out things
like the Twitter files where we know
without question 100 proof positive the
government was coordinating with Twitter
and Facebook sake even admitted a year
and a half ago but nobody cared about
Facebook uh that they were censoring
people uh at the behest of the
government it is that is it's a
violation of the First Amendment that's
that's basically it but
the show just goes on well you're seeing
the mainstream media screaming about
that right oh I guess we're not no
exactly that's the problem yeah so we
know about it yeah you know Fox News
covers it you know a couple conservative
Outlets but by and large the vast
majority of American public is
completely unaware of what happened
there because they're being distracted
on their little news feeds by the
Kardashians or you know whatever you're
getting
is that a push and pull that you always
have to deal with as a senator that you
probably could get more done on the
ground just focusing on Wisconsin but
you're part of the federal machine too
obviously as a senator so that it's it's
almost distracting from where you can
get concrete things done well again the
things I want to get done or reduce the
burden of the federal government so when
people come into my office if you're
looking for a government handout I'm
proud to go to the you know the Democrat
senator from Wisconsin if you're looking
to help get the government off your back
you've come to the right office so I'm
here you know
try to uphold the vision of our founding
fathers you know yeah we need some
government you can't live in Anarchy
can't live in chaos so you need some
government but needs to be limited
because our Founders they came from
tyrannical regimes they realized as
Government grew their freedom recedes
and let's face it freedom is the
essential ingredient in America it's
it's the freedom
that people use to dream and Inspire and
build and create this Marvel we call
America it's not big government big
government crushes those those dreams
big government takes away that freedom
um so you know my my goal here isn't to
bring home the bacon to Wisconsin my
goal is to shrink the size of federal
government so wisconsinites can Aspire
and dream and build and create let's
let's do a couple of other of the big
ones uh this Ukraine situation which we
are I think it's around 160 billion
dollars now it's weapons it's not a
declared war but at some point in my
opinion if you're funding a war forever
you're kind of at War
um I think you're pretty much in in the
same spot as that what what do you make
of this is there any off-ramp every week
we have spokesmen telling them no
there'll be no negotiation I mean it's
all very bizarre to say the least I'll
give you a little more fulsome answer
because I think it requires one
um yeah I was chairman of the European
subcommittee on Sunday Foreign Relations
ranking member I've probably been over
Ukraine as much as just by any of my
colleagues right I was at poroshenko's
inauguration I was the only member of
Congress at zlinkos rosalinski's
um
so Lincoln was the doctor that uh
um but yeah so is zelinski's
inauguration I thought he was the real
deal I know the Ukrainian people are I
mean they want to shed themselves of of
the legacy of corruption and to describe
it for you his prosecutor General
uh when I was over there I said here let
me describe corruption Ukraine we have
something like 22 000 prosecutors in
Ukraine we don't pay them well but they
live like kings
I mean that's the endemic corruption
okay so the maidan that was a scream and
we want we want what you have in the in
in the west I mean I have nothing but
sympathy for that right I have nothing
for sympathy for a country and for its
people that are invaded by an evil
war criminal and that's who Putin is
okay so I don't want to give any Aid in
Comfort to Putin whatsoever and I
want to support the the courageous
people of Ukraine
but
I think there is certainly a way of
preventing that Invasion to begin with
but but not not under by not obviously
okay so so once invaded uh once the the
one opportunity we might have had when
Russia was you know felt resistance you
know because the Courage the Ukrainian
people and the support of the West which
I supported that first tranche because
you know partly because we had to
replenish our Munitions that we you know
the commander-in-chief can just deplete
our stockpile so we had to replace those
as well
there was a moment in time
it was a glimmer hope where maybe Russia
would say well we've been off for you
more than we can shoot let's
let's return back and let's end this
but that was quite a while ago
now the reality situation is you know
you don't have a fair fight here uh
Putin can continue to send in cruise
missiles and bomb population centers
infrastructure I mean this this war just
continues to grind on and just more and
more of Ukraine is destroyed now both
sides are losing individuals but you
know certainly when I've asked people
the state department well what's the
public opinion polls in Russia there's
highest part of the war well why why
wouldn't they they've got Putin's
propaganda they're not getting their
cities bombed
so it's a completely unfair fight
there's no way Putin's you know gives up
on this there's no way it's existential
for him
so
it's a reality I hate
but at some point in time people are
everybody's gonna have to face a reality
every day that this goes by
the eventual outcome just gets worse and
worse and worse and worse it doesn't get
better so when you hear our state
department or even Biden saying the
ukrainians don't have to negotiate which
is what they've said repeatedly over the
last couple weeks I mean what do you
make of that
how does this get better
give me a scenario in terms of where we
turn this thing around and and you end
up with a better result than what you
have right now if you if you were to
just stop fighting right now how does it
get better
by continuing the fighting again it's a
horrible reality I I hate saying this
because I don't want to give any Aiden
Comfort to Putin I guess I would just
ask everybody including Putin right now
this is a lose-lose situation there is
no other than maybe China wins okay
um but I guess I would just ask
everybody to kind of temper
what they're thinking uh
we shouldn't be contemplating going to
war
with either Russia or China
there's no good outcome on that
okay they're they're kind of coming
together right there's there's no good
outcome on this I mean we've got to
recognize reality situation I mean China
is growing their military their Navy
um you know they get a lot more bang for
the buck what they spent on Military uh
so again it's it's maybe not a reality I
like to contemplate but it's reality
have to accept so I mentioned that I saw
you a couple weeks ago at this blueprint
event in Florida that governor desanta
was holding a bunch of Governors and
senators and Congress people obviously a
lot of your message definitely resonates
with with the Trump side of things what
do you make of this push and pull over
the last week or so and what's going on
there well I've always been a firm
believer in Ronald Reagan's 11th
commandment
um and I've always thought no matter
whether it's for a school board position
or Primary in a state race or for a
national one so your best strategy as a
candidate in a Republican primary is
show Republican voters how you defeat
the radical leftists are going to be
running against
you know show people what you bring to
the table your qualifications and don't
denigrate the the other guy who just or
gal who just might be our candidate
because you know it's a team sporting
whether whether you're the candidate or
somebody else is we want that
the eventual nominee Republican or
conservative nominee to win
yeah and by the way talking to enough
Republican voters most people agree with
that I mean they want to hear the
positive things about you that they want
to hear the negative things against the
Democrats and the radicals okay how are
you going to defeat
the Democrats as opposed to how you're
going to rip your Republican opponent so
I just personally don't think that's a
particularly good strategy
yeah I keep saying to people it's the
two things that I'm looking for and that
I think my audience is looking for
competency and the ability to
communicate it you give me those two
even if we disagree on some of the
periphery it's like that that'll be
that'll be just fine are you uh would
you say you're hopeful that we can you
know turn this America back around to
what these guys were fighting for so I
would say the number the normally I
start out speeches I just want to
obviously I'm not the most uplifted
I've also too yeah you're much better
off getting me as a speaker like where
there's their cocktails around you know
kind of take the edge off a little bit
yeah
um we can make that happen right now you
know the uh
again I I'm big into reality I mean I've
come from a manufacturing background it
doesn't do any good you can't solve
problems if you're not willing to
acknowledge the that you have a problem
you're not you know deluding yourself is
never a good strategy and you know I've
been pointing out to audiences that
Venezuelans voted themselves into
poverty an oil-rich Nation a successful
South American Nation
one election they voted themselves on
and put themselves on this destructive
path uh right now America is on a very
destructive path
um
again picking up the theme that
conservatives haven't truly grasped
how effective and pervasively the left
has infiltrated these institutions
um
you know we we our eyes are open we
think we see the truth this just looks
like Governor Sanders said this is
normal versus crazy I mean we know we
know we're normal okay
but we have to we have to understand
this crazy
has not been defeated if anything it's
it's still on the rise you got to give
the devil is due okay so we're gonna
have to advise strategies and how can we
effectively push back on this because
it's all all the stress being done on
the radar remember how obviously the
left
is teaching our children critical race
Theory obviously obviously they're
pushing transgenderism on our children
they'll never admit it
is only probably covid and online
learning that brought it to the surface
and brought us the attention to parents
that that wasn't you know the pandemic
was an Awakening for a certain
percentage of the population but
probably not a majority
and again the majority of the Americans
still get their news from Legacy Media
they're they're not going to be talking
about this stuff I mean you don't see 60
Minutes leading with an expose on you
know transgenders and being pushed in
our children or critical race Theory you
know inflaming the The Divide between
racial no they actually put they'll do a
lie a hit piece about someone pushing
back on it yeah I mean right now we've
got a Wisconsin Supreme Court race going
on it's crucial I mean the left realizes
because if they can this will flip the
court if if the the radical leftist the
judge wins this thing okay so the left
realized that that you know she'll
become a super legislator and Wisconsin
Supreme Court will become a super
legislature and they'll overturn
whatever games we've got they'll
redistrict and we may lose two House
Seats and so the the left is pouring
millions of dollars into this race
there are credible charges against the
the liberal Justice okay she married
when she was young and an elderly I
think it was a judge she had apparently
had a drinking problem uh abused him I
mean elder abuse these are these are
incredible allegations from people you
know a stepson other people that are
willing to put their you know name
behind this stuff
you know freely use the n-word in her
official capacity in the court
okay now what I'm saying I haven't even
heard about this at all precisely you
need to know if that or if those
credible allegations were attached to a
republican candidate local news stations
they'd be breaking into the first moon
landing to bring you this important news
instead what local news is doing is they
are covering the fact that she is saying
she's gonna
Sue these journalists for defamation
so again you're completely marginalizing
the charge and all you you're not
covering the charges you're just
covering the she's being defamed
so
it's not again it's not a fair fight
it's not a Level Playing Field and the
sooner we come to that realization then
start developing strategies around that
um
it's the only hope we do have but no I
I'm
I'm not the world's greatest Optimist
when I when I hear someone in college I
want big Optimus well okay you know good
luck you know where's your head you know
I always say to people I'm a world weary
Optimist I I don't think and I I suspect
you probably are too in a certain way
that you probably couldn't really do
this every day if you didn't believe you
could affect change
yeah okay I mean again I I have to
believe the truth has its own power
which is why
you know my dedication over the next six
years literally is pursuing uncovering
and exposing the truth all right then I
got two more for you in short order if
your phone rings and it's maybe one of
those guys that we talked about earlier
either Trump or DeSantis or maybe
somebody else and they say hey I could
use some help here you know VP something
like that does that have any interest to
you I mean clearly clearly you're a
fighter I mean that's obvious
for I would not expect that okay you
know maybe in you know helping out the
administration that'd be hard you know
listen if you get called on by you know
a president-elect or something like that
to serve your country I mean it's a
thing I was called on here that's why I
did it
um that'd be kind of hard to turn down
but I certainly don't expect to be
offered something like vice presidency
then I got one more if your phone rings
and it's Chuck Todd and he says you want
to do Meet the Press again absolutely
last time I was on there you know truck
was saying it was hard to do this uh
remotely yeah yeah bring me in the
studio track
just you know pick up the phone was it
their offer to only do it remotely
well I I wasn't wasn't available so no
I'm happy but I I offered right right on
there yeah let's do it yeah the phone
hasn't rung yet
so he had me on and it kind of blew up
after January 6th it was two years later
blew up again it wasn't my intention to
blow it up but at some point in time you
go looking at a every two years you know
so I've got a regular gig I Meet the
Press I guess but no listen I
I'm not afraid to defend what my beliefs
are in truth be told I do like to argue
I think it's a it's a really good way to
flesh out
you know the issues and by the way if in
the end you know I'm defeated an
argument I'll change my position
you made some pretty good points there I
mean that's
that's the way life is you have to have
a flexible mind you have to have an open
mind I think that's one of the things I
found most disturbing during the
pandemic still is just the the lack of
open-mindedness
it's like here's here's the narrative
here's what our you know the cartel is
telling us so now again the
disappointment of doctors not not
primarily being responsible to their
patients you know just because I I I've
heard the tragedies in hospitals a
family members going please God just try
Ivermectin just please give it to him
don't do it don't do it and then just
watch little everyone die and they
couldn't even be buying they're they're
prevented from visiting and it's
that has not been exposed to the extent
it should be I mean the the what
happened in hospitals the the lack the
loss of freedom
when you checked yourself in the
hospital which is why a guy like Paul
American my my uh second opinion event
just said you know
I hate to say it but the hospital's like
the last place he would go and again he
was critical care specialist I mean he I
mean here's a guy just real quick
um because it was really powerful tell
you you should put the link onto my
Rumble account on a second but but his
testimony this he's he's critical care
specialist so he's taking care of
patients way later than he should okay
but he has a 50 percent
death rate of the other people
because he's using all these things so
his death rate is 50 of his colleagues
so what do you think the hospital did
pinnamon kick him out I don't know what
they did is they took away his his tools
they forbid him
from using Ivermectin these things
including vitamin C
but the elected with seven patients and
this is a powerful testimony so they
tied my hands
they took away my tools
so all I could do is sit by and watch my
patients die
including like a 30 year old mother
that's what hospitals that's what the
covert cartel did and now they're out
destroying people like you know so they
took in the end they took away his
hospital privileges so here's a a
world-renowned critical care specialist
really can't practice in hospital
anymore I mean they're they're taking
away certifications of these doctors uh
suing people like Peter McCulloch you
know terminating their employment
they're going to make an example of them
of course that's how they kept everybody
else in line
I'm synthetic with that doctors they
spend you know a decade Plus getting
trained getting their certification you
know if they've got 300 000 with the
student loans to pay off they have to
make a living plus they want to be
doctors to help people
they just couldn't step out of line or
else they risked losing it all that was
purposeful
I can see why Chuck Todd only does this
once every two years but I'll do it more
than that how about that happy to come
back pleasure Senator thanks for having
me on
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell